the decision you make doesn't turn out  to be the right decision  i move on how do you move on like how  are you not doing i'm not over judging  myself  i make decisions super fast because if  i'm right i'm right and if i'm wrong  who gives a [ __ ] i'm sitting up here as  a byproduct of getting facebook  twitter youtube instagram snapchat  linkedin  right i spent a lot of time on peach  on social cam on vero on viddler  those didn't work out when you make  decisions and you don't dwell  the net outpaces you're trying to be  three for three you want to be three and  oh three right decisions no wrong  decisions  i'm trying to be 118 to 92. everybody's  looking for perfection because  perfection is the disguise  of insecurity i'm just doing because i'm  not worried about the ramifications  as long as you're not dead or out of  business no mistake  is a big deal